o Olá gente meu nome é Samuel Marques e
para mim é um prazer estar aqui no Fedex
sendo convidado pela fap para falar
sobre o assunto que tem muita vez sobre
a minha vida né então o tema de hoje
sejamos todos anti-racistas e eu espero
que vocês gostem nessa palestra bom é
primeiramente a gente precisa entender o
que que tem a ver essa palavra
antirracista e essa proporção que ela
está tomando hoje infelizmente de acordo
com essas proporções que o mundo está
projetando essa palavra anti-racism
militância bem tomado um lugar negativo
a sociedade mas a gente precisa
redefinir essas palavras que entender
que essas lutas são extremamentes
importantes para manter a sociedade sã e
para é trazer os direitos das pessoas
negras e fazer com que elas sejam se
o que possam exercícios direito suas
funções como todo e qualquer outra
pessoa da sociedade né Eu sou negro num
país racista minha família negra a gente
passa por coisas que só Deus a gente
sabe o que que é passar a maioria das
mexer zojila trabalham em em serviços
que exigem esforço físico e mental Então
aquela ideia da mulher frágil sensível
não é dado e nunca foi dado a mulher
negra pelo contrário a mulher nem leva
aquela mulher batalhadora guerreira e
tem que sempre que está disposta e nunca
pode estar sensível e frágil e a Jamila
Ela traz isso muito bem em lá atrás essa
questão a trabalha muito bem essa
questão que a gente nomear Quem são
coisas com as mulheres são essas que
homens são esses porque a gente tem que
diferenciar E como que essas lutas
ocorrem de forma diferente tá então a
gente tem que entender a particularidade
dessas pessoas
é bom que isso isso ocorre né E como que
como que essas coisas como que as
relações vão ocorrendo porque o racismo
ele é ligado a todas as questões ao
machismo a a tudo a tudo é a
interseccionalidade que a Carla
akotirene aborda muito bem no livro dela
sobre com esse tema e
interseccionalidade da feminina de furar
e dessa edição muito boa também que eu
indico a vocês é importante lembrar que
o anti-racismo ele é um objeto de ação e
não uma coisa para gente ficar olhando
admirando não ele precisa ser
anti-racista é um objeto de movimento de
ação que a gente tem que ser a todo
momento não adianta a gente falado
antirracista e não para ficar um
anti-racismo sabe é Como dizia Angela
Davis em uma sociedade racista não
adianta não cometer racismo tem que ser
anti-racista
Oi e aí precisa trazer importância dessa
palavra de novo né E porque falar de
racismo é necessário entendendo das
pessoas negras simplesmente porque o
racismo ele ocorre somente com uma
relação de poder o racismo ele é uma
relação de poder entre quem tá em cima e
quem tá embaixo por exemplo as minhas x
elas descarregavam a água em troco de
alguns reais ou litros de refrigerante e
isso com cinco e oito anos de idade
então racismo tira essa essa esse
direito de ser criança esse direito de
aproveitar os momentos porque ela
estiver na que amadurecer muito mais
rápido do que outras pessoas tiveram
elas não tiveram oportunidade de fazer
faculdade não tiveram oportunidade de
ter uma qualidade de ensino melhor se
hoje eu tô aqui se hoje eu tô no
processo de faculdade enfim é porque
muitas pessoas vieram antes de mim minha
vó ela abriu o mundo e muita coisa lá
não tinha ela tinha como
o básico Então ela abriu o olho muita
coisas mexida abrir mão de muita coisa
eu sou muito grato é isso porque hoje eu
estou aqui por causa de um passado por
causa de dança e solidária que abriu o
caminho para mim abrir o caminho e por
isso é importante a gente que nós pessoa
Inês possa dá valor a esses caminhos
aberta se assustando as pessoas que
tiveram que morrer para nós chegarmos
aqui hoje e podemos estar aqui falando
por mais que vivamos em uma sociedade
racista podemos estar ocupando os
espaços e isso é fruto de Muita batalha
antes da gente tá é dentro raça uma
relação de poder quando por exemplo é o
amensalismo é uma questão a relação
ecológica né Por e valorizando por vocês
por exemplo o elefante né muito grande
A Iá formiga no chão lá grama programa
programa quando esse elefante pisar na
grama ele impede a a grama de receber
pelo momento um período ou até por
várias horas luz solar ou seja fazer
essa fotossíntese não é produzir ali
açúcar né para poder se alimentar
entretanto e a formiga também porque ele
pisa e mata formiga ou insetos sem saber
que está matando mas um racismo as
pessoas que têm o poder tem a força de
elefante que pegam essa força e Fini
privilégio elas piso e massacrou meio a
minoria elas têm noção da força dela ela
não fazem porque não querem fazer elas
fazem porque elas sabem que tem essa
relação de poder e tem essa diferença
essa questão do Poder Está sempre na mão
delas então vocês têm que entender que o
racismo essa analogia que eu trouxe para
você ter entendido que o racismo é uma
relação
o poder né mas um homem entende o seu
tamanho Diferentemente do elefante né a
gente precisa entender gente é a partir
de quando o quartinho assim usar ela
começou a virar o quartinho da empregada
partir de quando escotada começou a ser
o desemprego a desigualdade sabe então a
gente tem que entender isso E como que o
racismo ele vai evoluindo porque eu digo
que sempre que o racismo ele é uma
estrutura muito bem organizada e a gente
também tem que está organizado para
poder combater o racismo porque ele é
uma estrutura organizada Desde quando os
senhores começar a seu esse ou e não há
nenhum problema em ser liderança Mas
quem chega na liderança E por que isso
acontece porque existe muito discurso da
meritocracia sabe não há nenhum problema
é que para liderança Mas quem chega
nesses lugares porque na meta crescendo
no Brasil na verdade pessoas ficam a
porque tem conta porque tem assunto
afirmativas porque as pessoas querem
sempre as pessoas que negam isso para
sempre competir quien es
É mas não entendo de problemas sociais
que nós vivemos então por isso a gente
tem que se engajar e tem que ser em
racista e tem que defender essa causa a
gente não pode ter medo de falar sobre
anti-racismo como diz de João Gates
iluminado pelo Efeito Dominó que derruba
a peça preta mais de 500 anos a gente
não pode a gente não pode deixar com que
o racismo a fome as nossas lutas dizia
Paulo Freire né educação não transforma
o mundo educação transforma pessoas
pessoas transformam o mundo infelizmente
a maioria das pessoas negras não tem
acesso a uma educação de qualidade e
forno Espalhe educação é muito
interessante porque por exemplo quando
você tem uma planta em casa e você não
sabe como cuidar dela você pesquisa
enfim um canal de veículo midiático e
você diga como que cuidar uma pessoa que
sabe cuidar e você coloca ela todo no
substrato adequado não vale de quadro
sob iluminação adequada e sobre régua
adequada E por que que a gente não
consegue
o bebê essa diferença nos cuidados de
outras pessoas que cada pessoa diferente
cada um tem diferente respeitar como
cada ser humano consegue ser bonito de
todo jeito que ele é e como que a gente
consegue tratar ele da forma com que com
que ele foi formado o a ser porque o
cada ser humano é formado a ser alguém a
personalidade Ela é formada de acordo
com as experiências que que eles vivem
né infelizmente a maioria das pessoas
negras não estão dentro das faculdades
não estão dentro das lideranças das
empresas e por exemplo quando eu falei
para você da questão das minhas tias
carregar em água ela tinha um irmão
chamado José no exemplo e ele hoje
falecido mas ele não se conformou ele
saiu foi se formar em economia na
universidade privada hoje já extinta e
ele falar para minha avó vou tirar vocês
daqui vocês vão sair daqui
e é infelizmente ele morreu afogado os
quarenta e poucos anos e assim comissões
da minha vó também foram mortos afogados
minha avó dizia que parte dela se for
com ele e e a gente precisa entender
como que como que essas pessoas com as
pessoas negras elas elas pegam a sua
vida e elas destinam ela a maioria é a
ao trabalho para pessoas brancas e
quanto mais essas pessoas sobem mas as
pessoas negras descem a gente tem que
entender que é um estado que decide quem
vive e quem morre que é um chá do decide
quem sobe e quem desce que é um estado
que decide quem fica rico que fica pobre
porque a minoria em minoria mesmo que
sai nessa situação e emerge para outra é
porque Muita batalha veio um monte dela
não é um caminho sozinho não é um
caminho trilhado sozinho é um caminho de
muitas pessoas tiveram com ela e tiveram
que está a
e essa essa luta meu tio foi Luther King
como muita como muitas pessoas quantas
quantas quantas pessoas nele a gente vai
ter que perder para trazer importância
ao antirracismo a a questão de não
cometer esse esse racismo quantos George
Floyd quantos miguel's quantos abre-alas
taylor's quantas pessoas vão ter que se
mortas para a gente entender quantos
pedaços de nós tem que ir embora para a
gente começar a entender importância da
luta anti-racista sábio está vivo hoje
gente é um direito ou um milagre na
minha vida é um milagre eu sou fruto de
muita oração minha avó deu será sempre
dizia o anda cheiroso se arruma leva o
documento Não mexe em coisa não anda
pessoas erradas e a gente vai ser
entender que o racismo ele traz essa
questão do Comércio deve suportar uma
sociedade que não julgue a gente mas
nunca Essa sociedade deve mudar
eu posso suportar como neste Canon mas
sempre como a gente tem que mudar se ao
padrão eurocêntrico e como que a gente
deve se comportar deixar esse
animalzinho para ser um ser humano
socialmente uma ser humano negro
socialmente comportado né infelizmente e
a gente vai se entender que não é a
experiência que ela passou ela trabalhou
minha vó né trabalhou a vida inteira
como doméstica para pessoas brancas e
enfim ela não saiu do Brasil e não pode
fazer uma faculdade infelizmente porque
a gente tem que entender essa estrutura
racista e como isso prima As pessoas de
fazer é o que elas podem fazer alcançar
o seu máximo de vida e a gente tem que
parar de falar e as pessoas tem que
parar de falar E tem que entender que
isso não é mimi isso são coisas que eu
passo que a pessoas negras passas ele se
está cansado disso pessoas negras hoje
foquem no seu futuro
É eu sei que é difícil Quantas coisas
enfia passa mas lembre-se das pessoas
que passaram por nós e tiveram um filho
nesse caminho difícil e vocês são o
futuro disso mantenham suas forças não
tenho sua fé e a gente vai mudar isso e
a gente tá mudando isso a gente está
chegando a gente tem que abrir um charme
está a nossa geração seguinte sejam
veículo de transformação sejam todos
anti-racistas é e para falar em relação
de poder essa questão de estranhamento
quando a gente fala de racismo as
pessoas não querem falar Não não toca
nesse assunto porque se tornou algo
estranho as pessoas não querem chegar
nesse ponto e é interessante que Jorge
oro em seu livro 1934 ele faz essa
questão Essa realidade histórica né é a
questão dos dois minutos de ódio e
realmente está vivendo em dois minutos
de olhos o tempo todo alguém exaltado e
outra pessoa é humilhada é e a gente
tu faz isso no automático e esse essa
cultura do cancelamento de não dá a
oportunidade e cancelar as pessoas por
todo e qualquer desvio de discurso E aí
que tem que entender que o racismo ele
traz ele traz essa questão e quanto uma
eles cancela essas pessoas que falam
sobre o rafinho mas esse problema é
agravado porque a gente esquece toda a
luta em é é um fenômeno cancelamento que
uma luta ela é trazida falando de forma
erronia mente mais toda luta feita
corretamente do passado ela é cancelado
também ela é aniquilado tudo é
aniquilado então é infelizmente isso
acontece tão sem anti-racista é muito
mais com o adjectivo é uma ação não é um
anti-racismo é ser anti-racista sejamos
todos anti-racistas Deus abençoe
e tchau tchau tchau